ikhwan rosé dorado journalistes
espagnols à paris matteo gisèle bercy
rédacteur en chef de putsch médias et
son accent italien bien sûr bonsoir à
tous les deux
espagne et italie les deux pays les plus
touchés ce que ce confinement at il été
critiquée comme on peut le voir en
france
alors en ce qui concerne l'espagne
il a été accepté il a été accepté mais
c'est vrai que depuis un certain nombre
de semaines le gouvernement est de plus
en plus critiqué à tel point que le
gouvernement qui vient de faire passer
des justes et une prolongation de l'état
d'urgence et que lors du prochain
da prochaine prolongation s'il venait à
la demande et ça serait très compliqué
très compliqué de la faire passer déjà
au parlement puisque les partis de
l'opposition ont dit qu'ils vont pas la
voter et même les espagnols des citoyens
qui sont quand commencer à sortir dans
la rue nous depuis le 4 le 4 mai et puis
une partie de l'espagne aujourd'hui 50%
de l'espagne aujourd'hui commence à être
des confiné même les espagnols
commencent à être très très critique
envers le gouvernement et la façon de
gérer c'est le confinement et les
déconfinement il faut juste se rappeler
que l'espagne comme l'italie a payé un
lourd tribut c'est pratiquement 27 mille
décès en espagne depuis le début de
cette pandémie
c'est classique matteo joseph berti même
état d'esprit en italie beaucoup de
critiques vis-à-vis des autorités on
rappelle qu italie à payer également un
très lourd tribut
effectivement le premier ministre 12'
paix qu on était aussi son gouvernement
tente été l'objet de plusieurs critiques
tout au long de cette pandémie
parce que ils ont déjà pris des
décisions qui n'étaient pas très claires
un peu comment c'était le cas en france
et ils ont créé de la confusion en
citant la façon où ils ont communiqué
aux citoyens ce qu'il fallait faire ou
pas faire et puis on n'a pas compris
pourquoi par exemple ils ont mis
1 comment dire à l'index certains
régions parce que et la b1 elle avait un
couleur politique différent de celui de
gouvernement sans considérer si hadji
c'est bien ou pas en termes de
prévention sanitaire
il faut dire aussi que le premier
ministre giuseppe comté est désormais
affranchie du parlement dans les sens
que c'est passage devant les chambres
qui composent le parlement italien sont
plutôt anodine dans les sens qu' il n'y
a presque jamais des votes de confiance
de vote qui engage le gouvernement donc
il ya seulement de communication et donc
quoi qu'en disent par exemple d'autres
pays comme la hongrie qu'on a accusé
d'être un pays où les pleins pouvoirs
ont été données au premier ministre où
il les a obtenu 10 ans en italie c'est
pas très différent les sens qu'eux on
avez
et les mots de matteo salvini cet été
avait fait scandale quand il avait
demandé les pleins pouvoir de facto ils
voient que l'actuel gouvernement a
beaucoup de pouvoir ne rompt pas content
à beaucoup de personnes et même le
président de la république italienne qui
est un peu les garants de la
constitution ne fait pas grand chose
pour revenir à une activité
parlementaire qui est naturellement elle
aussi un peu confiné dans les sens
comment les parents en terre qui y
siègent avec les distances avec le
masque un peu comment on a vu aussi en
france ce sont les mêmes critiques
juan rosé dorado que l'on peut entendre
en espagne juan rosé dorado je ne sais
pas si vous êtes encore avec nous
manifestement la liaison de ta peu
compliqué vous n'aurez entendez ce sont
les mêmes critiques que l'on peut
entendre qu'ils font écho en espagne et
en italie on vient les entendre avec
mateo gil alberti tout à fait ce sont
les mêmes les mêmes critiques que vous
avez le
le gouvernement définit le position
espagnole comme une opposition fasciste
et de l'autre côté la position du
gouvernement qui est un gouvernement
totalitaire donc en espagne le
gouvernement est obligé de passer devant
le parlement pour demander la
prolongation des l'état de d'urgence
mais les critiques sont les mêmes tout
d'abord parce que par exemple imaginer
connaissent pas le gouvernement ne veut
pas donner les noms des experts qui
conseillent le gouvernement en matière
de confinement et déconfinement ce qui
est interdit par la loi puisqu'elle a
obligé le gouvernement a donné qu'il est
quels sont les experts qui les
conseillent le gouvernement ne veut pas
donner les noms désespère un
gouvernement qui a travaillé tout seul
dans son coin sans l'accord des
communautés autonomes d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui vous savez le système d'aidé
confinement espagnol est assez compliqué
c'est un système en 4 face distante à
aujourd'hui on est pour la moitié des
espagnols on fasse une mais il reste
encore la deux et la trois arrivées et
s'efface et les façons dont on passe de
10 face à une autre des de confinement
ne sont pas claires non pas c'était bien
expliquée ni aux espagnols lui au
gouvernement autonome qui doivent gérer
aussi cette façon donc la critique est
une critique d'un côté politique il ya
bien évidemment la critique économique
puisqu'on sait que l'espagne bat
beaucoup souffrir décès et deux mois de
confinement
parce que l'économie est qu à l'arrêt et
puis il ya aussi une critique sociale
bien évidemment les espagnols se pose
beaucoup de questions je vous le dis
c'est dire beaucoup d'aidé c'est
aujourd'hui par exemple il ya plus des
45 mille médecins aides soignantes
infirmières etc qui ont été contaminés
par les coronavirus c'est ce qui fait
que beaucoup d'espagnols aujourd'hui 10
au gouvernement tout simplement qu'il
n'a pas su faire son travail et donc les
critiques sont les mêmes en italique en
espagne de toute évidence
maintenant il va falloir attendre et
voir si le gouvernement va payer un prix
politique à ces critiques
alors il ya des nuances et entre les
deux pays dans le dé confinement
en espagne alors que c'était l'un des
confinement les plus strictes hors
d'europe les terrasses de bars et de
restaurants vont rouvrir c'est assez
audacieux on ne le fait pas en france en
italie non plus sauf erreur de ma part
matteo jose alberti on imagine que c'est
une une catastrophe économique comment
le vivent les les italiens qui sont
évidemment de ferrante cette culture de
la terrasse des restaurants des pièces
d'or
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
manque aussi et qui est qu'on dira
alourdit le moral des gens mais
heureusement on a commencé à ouvrir déjà
certains la barre avec des des
conditions de distanciation social
extrêmement strictes dans certains bars
même il ya les serveurs qui change de
gants jetables à chaque passage des
clients et naturellement le nombre des
clients l'intérieur des bars doit être
très limité
disons qu'on ne peut plus faire à ce
qu'on faisait avant le classique café
comprend plusieurs fois par dans la
journée le cappuccino le matin ceci dit
que les italiens sont très attentifs de
la plus grand partie ou à ces mesures il
faut dire aussi que par contre les
déjà le 18 les bars les restaurants et
aussi les coiffeurs pourront rouvrir sur
un base régionale dans l'essence les
régions effectivement un peu comme
disait un creuset des comoni dadame
espagne vont ouvrir selon leurs règles
un peu à la carte pour aussi des confiné
un peu plus facilement de façon un peu
plus flexibles les endroits où il ya
moins de circulation du virus mais le
gouvernement pourra naturellement
intervenir ou bloquer ou reporter
certains ouverture et lundi apparemment
on devrait aussi recommencé à parler les
entraînements du shooter mais à huis
clos
alors ça c'est quelque chose que doit
vous enviez jeroen rosé dorado le foot
et on recommence en italie en allemagne
mais moi en espagne au d'espagne à ils
ont commencé à s'entraîner depuis
quelques jours et d'ailleurs on commence
à donner on commence à donner déjà donc
qui ne date à le championnat espagnol
et c'est la différence aussi par rapport
à la france les championnats espagnol
pourrait et commencer recommande
c'est à partir du 12 juin donc vous
voyez vous on retrouve une partie des
terrasses des bars et on retrouve le
foot va les espagnols sont en quelque
part un peu content quand même
on sait bien et en plus le psg pour une
fois s'était qualifié en quart de finale
on aurait pu battre les espagnols
et bien c'est raté ça doit être pour ça
je pense merci à tous les deux rosés
dorado beauté où je vous avertis d'avoir
été en direct avec nous sur rt france